ciao a tutti sì parliamone subito il blu
ray di titanic è arrivato in anteprima
comunque rivedendo il film per la
milionesima volta mi è venuta un'idea
la domanda è se titanica non avesse
avuto il suo budget di fanta milioni di
dollari sarebbe sempre stato un bel film
facciamo esperimento grazie alle moderne
tecnologie soprattutto all'iphone 5
gli scavi all'interno delle titanica
stanno portando risultati
un gruppo di sommozzatori infatti è
riuscito a trovare un preziosissimo
gioiello forse quello che in molti hanno
definito il blocco di carta stagnola di
luciano ed è visibile il mio preferito
sempre vecchia noi abbiamo ricevuto
lettere tutto vero beh siano proprio su
quella nave e vede quel prezioso
brillocco apparteneva a me ci parlero
sua storia ok va bene del resto non
vediamo l'ora di di raccontarvi i cazzi
miei e le tragedie che hanno costellato
la mia vita vedete a quel tempo il
titanic era considerata la nave più
migliore
di tutte e io insieme alla mia famiglia
stavo perdendo
che bello si va nella patria di
backstreet boys il titanic berti
ricordo ancora l'entusiasmo che si
respirava bordi del titanic
stavamo facendo un viaggio di dani kosor
titanica un viaggio che poteva fare solo
i cani vero di tanti mali
si no
il sogno della sapeva che ero depressa
perché non era riuscito a comprare il
numero di toccarli col poster di brian
ei che come stai usando sono jack jack
pillitteri rosalia de witte buche pierre
piazzare rosai e l'e booking che cos'è
un uomo la proposta
basta martin e voglio fidarmi voglio
togliere la mia vita anche corpo umano
rosalia caldo che ci farebbe da quel
condizione che stavo facendo gag e
serviva una ringhiera e quindi ho deciso
di prendere in prestito questa sai come
sono solo il suo insegnante
dai su rosaliani 4 1 dai attenta la
frangia americano per terra che cosa è
il blocco di carta stagnola dello scemo
ma è bellissimo delicato non so che cosa
fare per avresti un bel po vedete io
penso che che la vita vada vissuta e che
a caval donato non si guarda in bocca
detto che la cottura gallina vecchia fa
buon brodo del resto e perché no cielo a
pecorelle acqua a catinelle il rosso di
sera non è mai stato così verdi è senza
parole ma signori potete scusarmi noi
andremo a fare di loro
vuoi andare un vero party
tu non andrai mai più da nessuna parte
capito ubriacarti come una soccorrono
affidata non sono ubriaca ha mai capito
un cazzo che ti ho detto tu non dovrà
fare ma più nulla
tu sei cambiata da nessuna parte sei
cambiata cretina con un cervello di un
pollo arrosto che certo il mio crollo ma
che stai ferma così va bene
sì
un po più aggressiva
l'ambra fuori fuori un po più di
carattere
ok
immaginate di maggio e di essere la
serietà del titanic mangiati di essere
anche sebastiano del dynamic
immaginate di essere anche fonder per
titanic si sicure quelle più soli
il momento più erotico della mia vita se
ancora ci penso devo passare lo
strofinaccio allora che te ne pare
e bellissimo mi sentivo libera con sé
non serve intanto che
certo sul pensiero mio ferì di incorrere
nel ragazzo ma vedete di lì a poco
qualcosa stava accadendo
la pagina
rosalia dove sei
mastino ribaltato tocchi scalo romano
che si sono viste così unico e cassetto
non freddo artico una doppia punto c'è
perché non pettine fatto perdere il tuo
nome york rosanìa
e quello che ho fatto il cantante come
ti saresti pronto a chiamare justin
bieber non è bellissimo perché sei
prendono un canti una canzone insegno io
ero ricatto si possa andare a vedere ben
spies
sì